- Well, as I said earlier, we have some
of Keanu's John Wick
co-stars with us today.
So let's bring two of them out right now
from John Wick: Chapter
Four, please welcome
the manager of the New
York Continental Hotel
and his loyal concierge, Ian
McShane and Lance Reddick.
Give it up.
(audience clapping, upbeat music playing)
I'm like, I probably
smell my dog right now.
You're welcome.
Okay, so Happy National Puppy Day.
- Yeah.
- Please put pillows wherever you want.
Make yourself at home.
Yeah right here, watch this.
Watch. Watch what's gonna happen here.
Just like boop.
Please, say hi to the puppies
or if you wanna go pet them
at any moment, that one's
tearing up the thing.
That's awesome.
Let's talk about the new movie though.
What do you feel like
separates this John Wick
from the previous three?
- I feel like for the first time
we see Ian's character
- Vulnerable? or not vulnerable, but
- Where it gets where it
gets personal for him.
- Yeah.
- And his trajectory
throughout the rest of the film
is about, is about
loyalty and friendship and
for the first time revenge.
- And how sneaky he is.
- Well, I think, yeah, but
also I think I, you know
have a deep love for John.
- Yeah.
- I mean, like if he was, I
think if you asked anybody
their top list of assassins,
he would be number one.
- Yeah.
- Well, but in the
person, like that fanboy.
But he's like he is, but there's
also goes deeper than that
cause you don't quite never
know what the relationship
between me and Keanu is in the movie.
- But there's such a
loyalty with that story.
Yeah.
- Absolutely.
And him, and we feel protective of him.
And when, at the beginning
of this movie, you know
my world is taken away from me.
- I know. That's what I'm saying.
That's your character, yeah.
- That's where it becomes
as you said in episode one,
this time it's personal.
- And also in addition
to just how incredible
I mean, I, when I watched the
film, I, I was struck by how
I mean every, every one of
these films looks, looks great.
But how incredibly beautiful the entire,
especially a film that moves
so much and has so much
almost relentless action.
It's just, it's just
stunningly gorgeous to watch.
But the other thing for me is the theme of
how the theme of
family's such a huge theme
in this particular film.
More than, more than any others.
- For y'all and for your individual
- Well yeah, I was gonna
say literal family,
but also you see with the three of us.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- How it's not just the
family that you're born into,
but the family that you've created.
And how much we really are family.
- Yeah.
- Also, the fact that
Chad has done all four.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's very, very
important. Hugely important.
- [Kelly] It's a common thread.
- He and Chad have worked
together for, you know,
- [Kelly] Since The Matrix?
- [Ian] 20, 30 years, over 25 years.
So there's a deep understanding
of each other and a deep
empathy for the story.
And Derek Colstad wrote something which I
I think you've been very true to
and expanded upon in a very mature way
and in a very, you know, adventurous way.
It's just a shame we can't,
I can't kill anymore people.
- Yeah, well you're sneaky.
Let's not get past that.
I was like, oh with a twist!
I was like watching it
and I was like, cause there is a bad guy
in this that I just wanted to kill myself.
I was like, I hate him.
Welcome back everybody.
We are here with Keanu Reeves,
Ian McShane, Lance Reddick
from the new movie John
Wick: Chapter Four.
It's in theaters now.
Well, dogs hold special
meaning in the John Wick films.
So, so does friendships,
which we were talking about.
But in the latest movie, many
of the characters are faced
with choices that challenge
just how far they'd go
for a friend.
I think we've played this
game with you before Keanu
but it's time to find out
how far we'd go as well.
This is another round of
I would do anything for
friendship, but I won't do that.
- ♪ I would do anything for
friendship, but I won't do that ♪
- Alright I'm gonna hit this
button in our super computer.
We'll quickly calculate a
complicated friendship algorithm.
Sure. And spit out a question
that challenges our loyalty
to our close friends.
Then we each have to
say which path we'd take
and defend our decision
cause we're gonna be judged.
Here's the first test of friendship.
Here we go.
Your friend recently totaled two cars.
What's wrong with your
friend, first of all?
One accident technically wasn't his fault,
but still he asked you
to test drive your new EV
for the entire weekend.
What do you do?
- No way.
- [Kelly] No?
- No.
- Well first of all, I don't
know cars. So what's an EV?
- [Kelly] An electric vehicle.
- Oh, thank you.
- Maybe is it? No, no,
I'm guessing, I dunno.
- [Lance] Yeah. Okay.
- Yeah I, would you let your friend?
After just totaling two cars?
- It depended on how badly
he needed it and for what,
and if me driving him to
wherever he needed to go
was an option.
- [Kelly] Okay. You're smart.
All that thoughtful process.
Okay. I just would've been like sure.
- Oh.
- Yeah, I probably just
would've been like, okay.
I'll Uber if you crash
mine. What would you do?
- Oh
- Do you have an own a
vehicle or do you just,
I picture you just own a
garage full of motorcycles.
- I have a, I have a motorcycle
but I have a car and man,
if you need to take the car
for the weekend, have fun.
- Yeah, that's nice.
Okay. But it feels a little
bitter, but it's okay.
It feels a little not
full on, but it's okay.
- No, well it depends
what's happening, right?
You can't, there's conditions.
- Yeah. Like are you drunk?
Is that why you got in the accidents?
- Yeah, like why, did
the past form the present
which is gonna project the
future? I don't know man.
You just gotta go to the
character and if the characters
okay then take the car man.
- I love it.
Ian and I were like hard yes, hard no.
And y'all were like so
thoughtful about your answer.
- Well we're in a new age here, you know?
- No this, that had
nothing to do with new age.
- [Ian] You've gone
into another character.
- No, (bleep).
- I love it.
Okay, so here's the
next test of friendship.
Here we go.
Your friend calls and says
if his spouse asks you
where he was last, oh,
last weekend you should say he was
at your place watching
movies the whole time.
What do you do?
I'll tell you what I'll do
but y'all tell me first.
I'd call that significant other.
You know what, I'll go first.
I would call that significant other.
Be like, listen, some
shady (bleep) going down.
Like, need to collect your life.
What would you do?
- I'd say, this is a terrible line.
Can you repeat what you said?
And then put down the receiver
and then never answer the phone.
- Oh, it's the connection.
- Well it's different.
It sucks to put you or
anybody in that situation,
it's not really a friend.
- I know it is not.
- [Ian] That's not a friend.
- Oh, it is not.
Would you cover for your friend?
- Nope.
- Okay. I wouldn't either.
- I, I mean, I wouldn't call
I wouldn't call a spouse cause I'd be like
I don't wanna get in that.
- That's cause you're not a
woman, a woman would call.
- Oh okay.
- It's fine. Absolutely.
- What would you do? He'd totally cover.
He'd be like, alright.
(laughing)
- If I was a friend, like
if, if they were a friend
- Yeah. Would you ask why at
least they need you to cover?
- No. I'd just say what the
(bleep) are you doing, man?
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- Another hour dialogue about why
- Ultimately no, I don't
know if I, I would,
I would do what Ian did
and just try to get out of the situation.